bonsoir blanche saison merci d'être avec
nous on vient d'en parler avec paul à
cette crise qui ne cesse de finir on his
rennes pourquoi cette crise qui dure
maintenant depuis deux ans même cela
signifie sans doute que la magie
netanyahu ne fonctionne plus comme
auparavant en israël benjamin netanyahu
est au pouvoir depuis 12 ans et sans
discontinuer il avait été premier
ministre pendant trois années
dans la décennie précédente et pendant
les dix premières années deux de ses
douze ans à chaque fois son parti le
likoud est arrivé en tête et il a pu
former une majorité
ce n'est plus le cas depuis deux années
parce que en effet le run j le régime
israélien est une démocratie
parlementaire et la knesset le parlement
chambre unique à 120 députés
il faut donc avoir soixante et une voix
pour avoir la confiance de cette chambre
et netanyahu y est parvenu avec des
alliances
il faut savoir que les élections se font
au suffrage universel mais à la
proportionnelle et que par conséquent
cela favorise les petits partis
cela favorise même les dissidences des
grands partis et donc il faut négocier
pour constituer une coalition pour
constituer une alliance
il y est parvenu pendant dix ans depuis
deux années et ne parvient plus est
effectivement à chaque fois il a préféré
la dissolution retourner devant les
électeurs
plutôt que de courir le risque de voir
quelqu'un d'autre
former un gouvernement alors c'est
exactement où on en est ce soir si le
celui qui a été chargé de former le
gouvernement par le président de
d'israël ne parvient pas à minuit ou à
hull et bien il restera à la knesset
soit à proposer un nouveau formateur au
président soit à recommander la
dissolution et c'est probablement cette
dissolution que monsieur netanyahou
souhaite alors évidemment
la formation actuelle la négociation
actuelle qui dure depuis trois jours est
très difficile parce que comme ça a été
dit dans votre sujet on y trouve un
parti de droite qui est un parti
nationaliste et religieux mais on y
trouve aussi des partis de centre gauche
était parti de gauche
et puis même probablement un parti
d'arabes israéliens ce qui est une
grande première et ce qui est
probablement le plus étonnant dans dans
ce qui se passe en israël depuis depuis
quelques jours donc on sera tout à
l'heure dans moins de deux heures
quelle est l'issue il est possible que
ça marche parce qu'il ya un vrai désir
en israël en effet de changer et de
changer de premier ministre après toutes
ces années netanyahu mais il n'est pas
sûr que ça fonctionne et auquel cas on
leur a à nouveau des élections et à
nouveau peut-être une difficulté pour
monsieur netanyahou à former une
majorité
alors admettons si la coalition se
former est-ce qu'elle serait viable
selon vous
ben on peut en tout cas être sûr que le
likoud s'emploiera à lui faire une vie
difficile et c'est ce que fait le likoud
actuellement bien entendu cela dit
évidemment le fait qu'il y ait un
nouveau premier ministre
le fait qu'il y ait le soutien d'un
parti d'israéliens arabe le fait que les
nationalistes religieux est probablement
le poste de premier ministre fera pense
à fera passer une sorte de vent nouveau
et probablement pendant un certain temps
ce gouvernement pourra amener des idées
nouvelles mais il est possible en effet
que obtenu de ses contradictions
internes
il ne puisse pas dirigé le pays pendant
très longtemps et où quelqu'un on
retournera devant les électeurs d'ici
quelques mois ou quelques années
et à l'instant que blanchemaison le
parti arabe ram fait savoir qu'il
formalise et son appui au projet de
coalition anti netanya
on verra les conséquences s'octroie
avoir peut-être dans la soirée toujours
en cas de former des sur de formation
des coalitions quelles pourraient être
les conséquences sur le conflit israélo
palestinien
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que les
institutions fonctionnent normalement
en israël la knesset a élu tout à fait
normalement comme c'était prévu depuis
longtemps un président de la république
qui prendra ses fonctions le 9 juillet
et se prévient de la république était le
président du parti travailliste
ce président de parti travailliste
monsieur herzog a connu pour avoir
lorsqu'il est venu prévient le parti
travailliste était rendre visite à mme
abou la baston qu'il le connaît et il
entretient des contacts avec le chef de
l'autorité palestinienne
bien sûr il n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
c'est un président en titre 4e
république mais il a quand même une
influence et on peut je pense compter
sur lui pour faire en sorte que le
gouvernement essaie de renouer le
dialogue avec l'autorité palestinienne
alors pour le reste et bien beaucoup
risque de se jouer au caire puisque le
président 6-6 a demandé aux deux parties
palestiniennes de venir au caire le
hamas et le fatah de façon à examiner
les conditions d'une réunification des
palestiniens et ceux ci est
effectivement un enjeu considérable
le président si si je crois a joué un
très grand rôle dans le cessez-le-feu
entre le hamas et israël
et maintenant ils souhaiteraient joue un
rôle important dans la réunification des
palestiniens sous l'autorité de
l'autorité palestinienne mais ceci est
en effet très difficile
merci coach raison expert en relations
internationales